We're the Kennedy Family, we've been in New
Zealand nearly 12 years this year.
We first moved to the North Island in Taranaki
and have worked our way steadily down the
country until we now live in Rangiora in Waimakariri.
We've met some great people and it's a great
place to live.
We really feel like we've made the right decision
in where we live at the moment, it's fantastic.
We took it very seriously, making the decision.
One, that it was right for us and we like
the country,
we've been made to feel really welcome.
It is now our home and the fact that we've
set it as our home, we thought that we'd take
the next step and become citizens.
We've been very lucky today, to have this
land on Waitangi Day and at the marae
has been really good.
We feel really privileged actually.
Saying the words, receiving the certificate,
it's quite special.
It's something we'll never forget.